thank you guys it's going to be here my
name is hans kim and identify as
gender-fluid thank you thank you
I am biologically male but my bullies
identified me as a [ __ ] I participate
they do not care a lot of my bullies are
like yeah you're book smart but we're
street smart
oh you're smarter with us on measure
more comparable convenient for you maybe
you're not smart maybe you're insecure
about your intellect and that's how you
committed an aggravated assault let's go
crying stop pleasure me it hurts so much
I don't understand all the things in
America they say prison don't drop the
soap
hey Jimmy don't pick up the soap baby
dramas like so much wine yeah there's a
bending over whether they get you if you
don't drop this out you still getting it
right you're just going to really clean
hands all that happens
what are these prisoners like man I want
to get that kid but he never drops us
something does he have a bundle we'll
never know there go Gators they don't
take no for an answer I have an agent or
the nose country of Chinese
I'm from a province in china called
south korea it's right next to japan
province yeah it's a tough time to be
Asian nowadays I think of a complicated
it got something mighty tough oh man
smoking weed like the cool guys you know
I'm Korean I'm not even Chinese okay
those bastards [ __ ] ruining Asians
for the second time I smell and you know
it just sucks because Canadians we don't
even eat bats
wheat dogs okay get it right Cooper all
amazed that the Chinese built a hospital
in ten days but if you're eating bats
you better be able to build a hospital
and take babies [ __ ] you guys
advanced t better be able to build a
[ __ ] sink and wash your [ __ ] up
oh I mean I don't want things that Asian
people to bring people eat dogs which I
understand is very shocking because in
America dr. tree like family members but
in Asia we treat our family members like
family members there's a little cultural
difference we head back home where
instead of buying an animal we love our
grandma
we should have both better in Asia
unless your baby girl always get sued in
the rivers that you're really good a lot
of my Asian friends make fun of me
because they're like kanji like T
General Tso's chicken isn't that just a
shitty Americanized version of something
authentically Asian and I'm like yeah
but semi my favorite movies rush hour 3
that's just kind of what I'm working
with
I am NOT a racist I hate people too I
just get to know them first you hate
people for their skin I think it over
their souls I was at an airport inside
Duty reading a book in Arabic which kind
of freaked me out
but then I saw pull the corner of the
page and put the book away and I was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
[Laughter]
not a racist
I love the Black Panther movie cuz that
movie like children and hero they could
finally wake up to and not just someone
like Martin Luther King jr. Malcolm X or
hurry did something to Rosa Parks of
Maya Angelou or Kofi Anan destitute
dozens of Washington Obama Oprah Sidney
Poitier Joe Frank Muhammad Ali Tupac
biggie
Beyonce now there's a fake person that
dressed like a cat
congratulations whether they're gonna
come out the yellow panda on with the
fun I think it's like that
Tanner as a white person saying tell it
what you white [ __ ] it should be
like hey this is my Mexican friend
tanner
that's a black cannon I am single I'm
out here looking for the ladies I think
they're beautiful I don't think I could
ever [ __ ] a dude I've never looked at a
beautiful woman I've been like wow she's
gorgeous but is there a version of her
that's bigger and hairier than less
kindness I would put that in the hole
never happens but I was fine Dennis do
you like dude were so lucky we're not
gay can you imagine it most of the
gender we were attracted to wasn't
attracted to his back and I was like wow
can't even imagine they must cry a lot I
don't understand people who say it's
Adam and Eve not Adam and Steve because
Adam and Eve we're not even a good
couple bit of weight because first of
all they disobey God and they ate of
fruit they weren't supposed to eat which
is kind of game and then everybody's
Cain and Abel and Cain murdered Abel
where they take it painted by some
people who raised a murmur there are
only three other people on earth to kill
the corner of the world's population is
[ __ ]
we got the bullets just move
your startup your [ __ ] together Jesus he
comes later my sister is the Christian
we grow Christian and the Asian people
we're just kind of weird because people
wrote the Bible they didn't seem to know
that ages existed I could even drop us a
line Asians way down with the fireworks
really proud of you guys the Jews we saw
tonight they're the great people I do
not mean to sound anti-semitic please
I'm canceling so since you just got my
crew mission trip if you don't know that
as the mission trip is when Americans go
to third world countries again your
profile pictures thank you
[Applause]